[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour un nouvel
entretien politique sur tv 78 en
entretien politique un peu particulier
aujourd'hui puisque je reçois un jeune
ambassadeur de l'omg ouanna guillaume
légère bonjour donc bien monsieur en
plateau vous avez 21 ans vous résidez à
mais dans une commune située près de
poissy et vous avez rejoint one depuis
un an à peu près et cette organisation
non gouvernementale qui agit autour des
enjeux du développement de lutte contre
l'extrême pauvreté et les maladies
évitables dans le monde co fondée
notamment par le chanteur bono du groupe
pew tout qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à
devenir ambassadeurs de cette
association one vient tout d'abord ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que one c'est une
organisation non gouvernementale de
plaidoyer c'est à dire que nous
défendons des causes et ses causes sont
principalement l'extrême pauvreté mais
également les maladies facilement
évitables donc moi je fais étudiants
vous l'avez dit j'ai 21 ans et je suis
étudiant en relations internationales et
donc je suis ouverte sur l'extérieur et
donc les enjeux de développement comme
l'extrême pauvreté ne tiennent vraiment
à coeur mais c'est des enjeux qui vous
touche vous avez participé à d'autres
associations vous êtes déjà engagées ou
sept ans premier engagement non non
depuis ma tendre enfance on va dire j'ai
toujours milité pour des causes
écologiques mais également dans le
secteur social donc actuellement je suis
bénévole dans le calaisis mais aussi en
ile de france auprès des exilés des
réfugiés et cet engagement de one
portait vraiment à coeur car c'est une
grande ong nous faisons beaucoup
d'action aussi bien sur le réseau de
manière physique et donc c'est pour moi
un plus d'être dans une ong cette
fois-ci de plaidoyer comment comment ça
commence à s'organiser au quotidien
justement cette action que vous pouvez
mener et puis on va en venir après à la
campagne qui s'ouvre dans le cadre de la
présidentielle est également que wayne
va mener mais au quotidien comment vous
agissez avec one j'ai intégré one du
coup en février 2022 dans le cadre de la
campagne inversant la tendance donc je
suis on va dire un nouvel élément voilà
dans l' ong mais nous avons différentes
actions à savoir que nous travaillons en
équipe nous sommes 75 à one en france
car il ya aussi des bureaux en afrique
ou en amérique du nord et donc nos
campagnes surtout là avant les élections
présidentielle et législatives nous les
menons au cours de festival lors des
entretiens et des débats politiques ou
nous n'hésitons pas à interpeller nos
dirigeants directement mais également
sur le terrain par le biais de
manifestations sur les réseaux ou nous
tweetons et nous interpellons
véritablement nos dirigeants directement
à travers de ses réseaux par des vidéos
voilà nos moyens d'action sans vraiment
multiples sans oublier bien sûr lettre
adressée directement à nos candidats
élus et la campagne qui nous occupe
actuellement et dont nous allons parler
et qui motive votre présence aujourd'hui
dans l'entretien politique c'est la
campagne inversons à la tendance elle
vise à interpeller et elle est candidate
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle sur la progression de
l'extrême pauvreté on va en voir
quelques affiches et puis on va
expliquer le pourquoi de cette campagne
inversons la tendance pour la première
fois depuis les années 90 on notait un
renouveau 1re départ en tout cas des de
ces mauvais chiffres de croissance de
l'extrême pauvreté c'est ça en effet
malheureusement donc vous avez sans
doute vu nos affiches auprès des qg de
campagne des candidats à l'élection et
puis dans les métros parisiens bref un
petit peu partout dont tribune justement
de ces images à à l'antenne et qui
explique cet habillage années 90 voilà
le non retour dans les années 90 du coup
une campagne un petit peu décalé car
malheureusement les années 90 reviennent
de nos jours pour le meilleur et pour le
pire on voit bien dans le domaine de la
mode saas est un loisir la mode et
c'est tant mieux mais voilà depuis les
années 90 à cause on connaît du contexte
sanitaire géopolitique les inégalités
remonte et l'extrême pauvreté en flèche
le seuil de l'extrême pauvreté c'est 1
29 dollar moins de deux dollars par jour
et ce seuil progrès ce qui explique
cette campagne basée sur les années 90
vous l'avez compris on a vu les
différents candidats avec des
photomontages il ya aussi un clip vidéo
qui a été tournée avec pascal légitimus
on va continuer l'échangé avec vous on
va juste regarder un extrait de ce clip
de ce petit teaser promotionnel
m'écouter
une dernière question 1 whatever simone
elle vous demande quel partenariat allez
vous créer avec l'afrique pour que les
futures relations entre nos continents
se fasse réellement d'égal à égal
moi j'ai un avis mais bon
alors vous êtes là
[Musique]
voilà bon écouter les candidats ont
jusqu'au 10 avril pour y répondre ils
ont de la chance
inversons la tendance c'est le nom de
cette campagne menée par l'omg one nous
avons l'un de ses ambassadeurs sur ce
plateau à cette campagne inversons la
tendance adresse aux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
et on l'a vu vous attendait des réponses
à travers ce petit clip humoristique il
est diffusé sur les réseaux ça ça fait
partie des actions que vous menez
justement également oui je vous invite
d'ailleurs tous vos téléspectateurs à
suivre one et one france sur lèze sur
les réseaux nous sommes présents partout
où anne france tirée du bas ong
concrètement aux candidats aux prochain
ou la prochaine présidence de la
république vous lui demandez quoi voilà
donc nous avons élaboré au cours de la
précédente campagne tout eu tout un
programme véritablement dédié à la
solidarité internationale nous nous
focalisons sur trois grandes axes tout
d'abord nous demandons aux futurs ou à
la futur président de la république
d'inverser la tendance vis-à-vis de
l'épidémie de mettre fin à cette
pandémie et surtout sur le continent
africain car c'est le continent le plus
touché surtout on a dit par l'extrême
pauvreté nous voulons également que ce
futur dirigeant prenne des mesures pour
me contre pour favoriser on va dire la
relance économique de ces états
africains et enfin d'agir comme un vrai
partenaire d'égal à égal avec ceux de
l'état aujourd'hui avec le la pandémie
qu il est aujourd'hui avec le conflit et
la guerre en ukraine vous avez le
sentiment d'être audible dans la
campagne présidentielle en dehors de ce
sujet de la guerre aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucun sujet abordé en effet c'est pour
ça que nous voulons mettre le
développement international et la lutte
contre l'extrême pauvreté et les
maladies évitables au centre du débat on
comprend bien aujourd'hui en fonction on
on va dire avec le contexte sanitaire
géopolitique
on peut comprendre que d un jeu plus
sécuritaire économique soit au centre du
débat mais nous sommes là pour dire oui
mais il ya aussi d'autres débats qu'ils
méritent leur place et qui mérite d'être
défendu et nous nous allons nous assurer
que nous faisons tout jusqu'aux
prochaines élections pour en parler pour
mettre ce sujet en avant car il ya de
vraies mesures à prendre si nous ne les
prenons pas de nouvelles pandémies de
nouvelles crises vont émerger dans les
années à venir on a le sentiment quand
même que alors au niveau des campagnes
présidentielles à chaque fois ces sujets
reviennent wano existe depuis 2004 dont
kiel quand même quelques quelques années
d'expérience les choses ont progressé
non pas du tout oui bien sûr avant la
pandémie voilà les inégalités tendait à
se réduire l'extrême pauvreté et
également et beaucoup de mesures ont été
prises lors de son quinquennat monsieur
matheron à augmenter la part du revenu
national brut consacré à l'aide au
développement
elle est passée de 0,30 est à 0 55%
l'objectif est d'atteindre des 0,7 pour
cent qui est une norme européenne d'ici
l'année 2025 donc pour ça ça va dans le
bon sens malheureusement nous on l'a vu
en fonction à cause du contexte
oui voudrais pas qu'à cause de ce
contexte en raison de ce contexte cette
cette cause que vous défendez et la
lutte contre l'extrême pauvreté soit ça
mis de côté ses ça car nous venons de
perdre 20 ans dans le domaine de la
lutte contre l'extrême pauvreté et il
est aussi une plateforme sur internet
pour que chacun puisse poser des
questions interpeller les candidats une
pétition qui est partagé sur les réseaux
sociaux tout ça est développé sur le
site de deux ong et une fois que les
candidats ont aussi fait leurs
propositions il y aura des comparatifs
pour que chacun puisse consulter ce
qu'ils vous ont répondu parce qu'ils
vont être interpellés ils vont
intervenir ce sera le 22 mars prochain
au théâtre du rond point à paris l ong
va recevoir les candidats les
ambassadeurs seront présents ses co
organisé avec nos confrères de
libération comment ça va se passer
concrètement mais avec vous et vous
l'avez dit nous allons recevoir
l'ensemble des candidats à l'élection au
théâtre du rond point le 22 mars
prochain au cours de la journée nous
poserons ne nos questions en
collaboration avec les journalistes de
libération aux candidats nous allons
leur demander par exemple s'il serait
prêt au cours des 100 premiers jours
après leur investiture à vacciner par
exemple 70% du continent africain il
cesse le continent malheureusement le
moins vacciner actuellement environ 15 %
de sa population a reçu une première 11
contre lacko vide voilà nous allons s'y
poser nous allons en fait essayer de
comprendre jusqu'où les candidats
seraient prêts à aller en matière de
développement et bien sûr les inciter à
faire plus tous les candidats ont
répondu présent les 12 alors
malheureusement je ne connais pas la
programmation exacte mais non non nous
avons contacté l'ensemble des candidats
et ils sont bien sûr encouragé à venir
voulez vous allez intervenir sur cette
sorte cette séquence directement je
serai présent vous aller les interroger
sur quoi vous avez déjà prévu vos
questions alors il faudra faire appel
dans le 2 mars pour pour entendre nos
questions directement néanmoins oui nous
allons savoir nous allons leur demander
quelles mesures concrètes il serait prêt
à prendre et s'il serait aussi enclin à
répondre à nos questions à nos demandes
on l'a vu le la question du vaccin mais
également des questions plus techniques
en matière d'économie sur la question
des dts que les pays industrialisés ont
obtenu du fmi c'est après ce sont en
fait des titres financiers spéciaux qui
ont servi à alimenter durant la crise
les pays industriels les pays on va dire
riches en liquidités s'il serait prêt à
donner ces titres au continent qu'un aux
pays qui en ont le plus besoin on va
préciser que l' ong one et et
apolitiques donc c'est une question plus
générale mais vous avez le sentiment que
tous les candidats vous entende oui on
sont pas tous sur la même longueur
d'onde ils n'ont pas tous les mêmes
propositions et bien malheureusement
c'est justement pour ça que l'omg
exister pour remettre au centre du débat
et les encourager tous aussi bien
l'extrême droite que l'extrême gauche à
agir pas que à l'échelle nationale mais
surtout internationale pour nous c'est
vraiment ça qui est essentielle vous
l'avez dit vous êtes étudiant en
relations internationales vous vous
engager auprès d'associations comme moi
né et d'autre part avant vous voyez vous
voyez où à l'avenir plus engagé en
politique peut-être ou pour vous ce
n'est pas encore de la politique que les
choses se font
malheureusement
n'inspire pas travailler dans le milieu
politique je suis plus engagé dans le
secteur de l'aide humanitaire d'urgence
mais l'un peut aller de pair avec
l'autre donc on ne sait jamais ce que la
vie nous réserve très bien merci
beaucoup qui obligèrent d'être venu sur
ce plateau jeunes ambassadeurs de l'omg
om qui lance donc sa campagne contre eux
à la progression de l'extrême pauvreté
dans le monde inversons la tendance
merci encore à vous on se retrouve
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]